Salut les Mentalos !
Petite vidéo tranquille, assis, pourquoi pas.
Je vous fais cette vidéo très tôt ce matin,
parce que je pars faire 2 tournages après, aujourd'hui dans la journée.
Donc si j'ai la tête du mec pas très réveillé
c'est pas totalement faux.
Aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler de 5 choses qu'on voit sur notre visage.
De ce que dit notre visage
pas forcément les micros-expressions, qui elles traduisent des émotions.
Mais on voit bien plus que ça sur le visage de quelqu'un.
Premièrement, on sait si vous êtes plutôt quelqu'un de terre à terre ou plutôt quelqu'un porté vers l’artistique.
Vous savez que sur la photo, on a toujours son profil préféré.
En tout cas, la plupart d'entre vous ont un profil préféré à montrer.
En Australie du Sud, Owen Churches a fait une étude là dessus
et cette étude a démontré, de manière scientifique,
statistique et rationnelle.
Ceux qui préfèrent montrer leur côté droit ou qui spontanément mettent leur profil droit
sont plutôt des scientifiques , des mathématiciens, des personnes qui sont très pragmatiques
très logiques, alors que celles qui expriment leurs émotions, donc on va dire
plutôt les créatifs
montrent leur côté gauche.
Ne me demandez pas pourquoi, on a pas la réponse, c'est une recherche statistique qui a été faite.
Je vous dis je ne savais pas non plus
c'est en faisant des recherches pour cette vidéo que j'ai découvert ça
et du coup je vais m'atteler à faire attention à ça aujourd'hui
et je verrais si ma propre expérience est en accord avec cette étude.
Deuxième chose, on voit également ce que vous mangez suivant la coloration de la peau.
Si vous avez la peau un petit peu orangée c'est pas forcément que vous avez fait des UV
c'est aussi parce que vous mangez correctement et que vous avez beaucoup de carotène en vous.
La carotène c'est une particule qu'on retrouve dans la carotte
et qui donne cette jolie couleur au visage.
C'est un petit peu plus jaune que la mélanine et ça se repère facilement.
Et bien les psychologues de l'université de Leeds et ceux de l'université de Saint Andrews ils ont fait la même étude en même temps, en 2014
ce sont aperçus que ces visages là étaient plus attrayant que les visages bronzés.
C'est à dire qu'inconsciemment nous sommes aussi programmé pour être attirés par des personnes qui ont une alimentation saine.
Regardez les visages et vous aussi vous saurez.
Si votre voisin mange de la carotte, ou a une bonne alimentation.
Troisième chose,
on voit sur le visage la manière dont les personnes se battent.
C'est encore plus vrai pour les hommes.
La vraie chose à regarder c'est la largeur du visage par rapport à la hauteur de la personne.
Plus le visage est large proportionnellement à la taille de la personne,
plus en général c'est un bon combattant, c'est un bon bourrin.
C'est un bon bourrin.
Et moi j'ai le visage bien fin
donc s'il vous plait ne m'agressez pas.
Donc je disais, quatrièmement
une des choses qu'on peut voir sur le visage et qui est aussi intéressante à prendre en compte
c'est la personne face à la douleur.
Sur des douleurs très rapides fulgurantes
ou sur des douleurs un petit peu plus longues
qu'elles soient physiques ou émotionnelles, il se passe beaucoup de choses dans cette région là.
En fait ce qu'il se passe c'est que quand on a mal on commence à froncer comme ça
mais c'est plus léger que ce que je suis en train de faire, c'est dur à maitriser,
mais quand quelqu'un de votre entourage par exemple, dis qu'il a mal et qu'il a besoin d'aide etc...
Vous pouvez regarder dans cette région pour voir l'intensité de la douleur.
C'est très dur de jauger comme ça par la parole l'intensité de la douleur de quelqu'un.
Vous pouvez le faire en regardant sur son visage des signes et des traces de la douleur
plutôt que d'essayer de jauger par la voix.
Et même si au départ vous n'avez pas de point de départ,
quand la personne vous dit qu'elle a mal, vous pouvez regarder son visage
et essayer de voir toutes les crispations de cette zone ici au dessus des yeux
et de le prendre comme point de référence pour voir si 10min après
la personne a plus ou moins mal
si elle fronce de plus en plus, ou de moins en moins.
Et enfin cinquièmement,
et c'est une étude que je viens de découvrir assez récemment
et qui est très intéressante,
elle est liée, non pas aux micro-expressions mais on est un petit peu sur le même travail,
on peut découvrir ce à quoi vient de réagir une personne
c'est à dire qu'on voit une réaction sur le visage de quelqu'un
et on est capable de remonter ce à quoi elle vient de réagir.
Par exemple est-ce qu'on vient de lui annoncer une triste nouvelle,
ou est-ce qu'on vient de lui demander de patienter dans une salle d'attente
ou ce genre de choses, et ça c'est intéressant parce qu'au delà de l'émotion
on arrive à caractériser un fait.
C'est l'université de Nothingham en 2012 qui a fait ces études là
et ils ont demandé à un panel de personnes de regarder des courtes vidéos où il n'y avait pas de son
et de dire, d'après eux, ce à quoi la personne réagissait.
Ils ont eu 60% de bonnes réponses, c'est quand même beaucoup 60% de bonnes réponses.
Et pour faire une phase test de comparaison puisqu'ils ne pouvaient pas vraiment avoir un panel placébo on va dire.
Il avaient organisé un QCM, donc il y avait de réponses où ils pouvaient cocher parmis toutes ces réponses laquelle était la bonne.
Et si on s'en tient aux statistiques du QCM ils auraient dû avoir à peine 20% de bonne réponses
si ça avait été complètement au hasard.
Y'a vraiment un écart qui permet de dire que non ce n'est pas un hasard.
A priori notre premier critère spontané est de regarder toute la région de la bouche et les réactions au niveau de la bouche.
Je vous avoue que c'est quelque chose que je connais, les réactions qu'on a au niveau des lèvres
mais pas assez pour l'associer comme ça à des réactions prédéfinies.
Dans l'étude par exemple ils ont eu 90% de bonnes réponses pour les gens à qui on demandait d'attendre ou de patienter
c'est beaucoup. C'est tellement beaucoup que j'ai commandé l'étude, je vais la lire.
Elle va être en Anglais donc ça va être un petit peu long de bien tout comprendre.
Ce qui est spécifique je vais l'étudier, en retirer ce qu'il y a à en retirer, et je vous ferais une nouvelle vidéo dessus.
Et bien j'espère que cette vidéo un peu matinale pour moi, mais qui est à 17h comme d'habitude pour vous, vous a plu.
Si c'est le cas, mettez un pouce en l'air vraiment, et puis j'en referais aussi dans ce style-là comme ça
ça me sert toujours aussi à voir si ça vous a vraiment plu ou pas.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé la vidéo, vous pouvez la compléter d'un petit commentaire sur ce sujet
ça me fait toujours plaisir de le dire parce que je lis, oui, tous les commentaires, oui, tous.
Dans les petites news, d'ici la fin de la semaine je sors la vidéo sur les mind maps
vous m'en avez envoyé pleins, c'est top.
La semaine prochaine je vais faire un concours avec 5 choses à gagner qui sont plutôt cool.
On me l'a proposé aujourd'hui.
C'est pas un partenariat, parce que je ne touche pas d'argent ou quoi que ce soit.
C'est vraiment l'occasion en fait de vous faire des cadeaux et je suis très content de ça.
D'ici la fin de la semaine il y aura également une grande nouvelle sur la chaîne.
Les vrais Mentalos savent de quoi je parle.
Et puis pensez à partager cette vidéo, pourquoi pas, et à vous abonner avant de partir si c'est pas déjà fait
puisque le Mental Vlog c'est déjà c'est grâce à vous qu'on est aussi nombreux, merci.
Voilà, je vous le dis, merci
Et rendez-vous demain à 17h, ciao !